I'm trying to say this in like the most
nice way possible because of how like I
truly feel and you know you got analysts
and um you got guys like skip that just
talk so crazy out on the media just
because they can skip I've never once
asked you to Hype me up or do anything
like that you did that because you saw
what I was doing on the field um like
I've never want you to jump on my coat
tail or you're the one that wanted me on
your show to come speak on your show uh
and I wanted to do my own route because
of your bad ties and who you are I did
not want to be partner with you and
that's just point blank simple so you
could drive whatever narrative or
whatever what whatever you want to be
but a person who's been all pro for
three years and however you want to put
it I guess I am not that guy and I got
to do more to be a guy whatever
narrative that drives your boat or
whatever you want to fit um um but go
watch the go watch that Packers Game and
Watch Aaron Jones follow me wherever I
went uh and you could say that they
blocked me but I mean Jordan love had
almost every accessible throw uh there
was so how can you get a quarterback if
you as a pass rusher you look for
opportunity for the quarterback to hold
the ball you know it like it it just is
what it is and that's just the game you
know it's tough and it's very
disappointing um and you know going into
this year uh there's just a lot of work
and a lot of culture that needs to be
established for us to be a Super Bowl
team I never believe I believe that uh
you know the Super Bowl is never won
really by the best team it's by the team
that can put together so obviously the
penalties hurt us again um penalties
hurt I mean look at the Ravens game I
believe the Ravens was by far the best
team um and they did not go on to win
that game I mean you look at penalties
you look at momentum shifting plays uh
it just it just happens to be that way
experience is a gift um and obviously
surrounded by really good players and
really good
coaching